it goes it goes it goes it goes it goes
it goes it goes it goes name review
today we have a very special episode of
meme review that's right
Sonic focus finally Sonic focus
Sonic focus name review sonic sonic ooh
Sonic's and where did he go wrong you
know how did we go from a cute little
fudge ball to this
why on God's earth does this exist and
why on God's earth
Isis exists and why oh god why if I
could remove anything from planet Earth
it would be the sonic totem sonic totem
please I can't live with this I cannot
live on the same planet I cannot share
the same planet with this when people
talked about the new Sonic movie you
know there was a tiny shred of hope
people thought the dream is real maybe
Vin Diesel is gonna act in it maybe it
could actually be good you know maybe it
could be good maybe I could actually be
good people had all kinds of crazy ideas
the fantasies went wild but as you all
know sonic fantasies they released the
teaser and people were excited
well what people don't understand is
that Sonic has suffered too long
Sonic is already dead and there's
nothing that can bring him back at this
point but what makes his downfall so
painful is that he actually used to be
cool
[Applause]
what people don't realize is that Sonic
retired long ago
he's living happy now these are all just
stunt doubles the thing is like even the
games have been bad for so goddamn long
and I know that anyone says who says
differently it's just purely out of
nostalgia or I am NOT gonna lie
the soundtrack fun Sonic R does make me
feel the sunshine okay
hey guys
[Music]
can you imagine a franchise recognized
by millions and millions and millions of
people that hasn't made a decent game in
what three decades I'm trying my best
gaza ming a little bit there I'm really
trying but I think what hurts the most
is that Sonic actually used to be cool
Sonic actually used to be somebody
goddammit
Sonic used to be the cool kid in town so
now that the trailer of the film is
finally out is anyone actually surprised
that this is the best they could come up
with it's a curse I am convinced it's a
curse at this point and you have to
understand that this comes from a place
of love I am the number one Sonic fan
okay maybe not that's impossible
has he not suffered enough isn't it time
to just exile Sonic and never speak of
him again
wouldn't that be better how much more do
you want to see this little Hedgehog in
pain
why aren't guards earth does he look
like the kid from human Jim mahadji you
know they spent multi million dollars on
this right you understand that for them
to then change it as they are now saying
Sonic the Hedgehog will be designed to
be changed following criticism you know
they're just gonna have to spend even
more multi millions and everyone going
oh it's a marketing strategy what if
paramount already have a good looking
sonic design and just showed us bad
version for marketing purposes see I
pulled a sneaky on you so many people
seem to share this sentiment you don't
understand no Sonic is cursed okay this
is the best they could do you had a
team of experts and the rest of frickin
Nicolas Cage literally put Nicolas Cage
in the Sonics if you know what put
Nicolas Cage and a blue spray can and I
will look like a better team sonic okay
ready
after knowing that they were the reason
behind the sonic remake unlimited power
now while God's earthly they listen to
remake I know a lot of people are happy
about this saying like oh it's great you
know they're listening to criticism it's
too flippin late ok it's not gonna
change the build it's just gonna make
him look different it doesn't matter
okay it's just if they're already making
this incompetent decisions why am I on
ironically pissed off about this thing
I understand Sammy now I'm 30
god damn it Daniel the cooler Daniel I
guess people brought up the point of how
lil they have to change for Sonic to
look somewhat decent so I guess they
thought hey alright I guess we can just
change that but also from another
perspective at this point I just want to
see it for the memes that's all I really
care about even if your expectations are
completely destroyed and your hopes are
crushed you feel no excitement about
anything else in life
memes can cure that at least these are
three sonic designs made by three
different shoddy people you can't
convince the other one yeah what did it
look so different how did this happen
why do I care I don't care I look how
many blue animations are you gonna flip
up upgrade go back I said go back see it
shouldn't be so freakin hard man the
pupil can expand up to 55% when you look
at something you love
oh my god it's adorable
good job Sega good job you did it
paramount on one hand gold on other hand
painful agonizing failure oh my god
goddamn it he looked like the dispenser
guy from Team Fortress amazing we regret
to inform you that
he decided to let you go in favor of
someone better suited for the role of
Sonic I way cuter Sonic I know who made
this but it's not listed anywhere it's a
water call it oh my god
shitty watercolour his average call yeah
Sonic is this real Sonic AMV gangster's
paradise 12 years from now there will be
a live-action Sonic will be based on my
video this cannot be real I have to
confirm this oh my god
oh well years ago I thought it was weird
that gangster's paradise out of all
songs - poor Sonic oh my god I need to
sit down oh it's edited it's an editor
to comment oh my god blew my mind for a
second that's the best thing I've ever
seen that's fantastic oh my god just
stop abusing Sonic if this is not the
change they make then I don't care it's
the only change they can make your Sonic
that is acceptable at least of my Sonic
standards
Wow see this looks really good - is that
true that actually happened
do they not test these things so they're
not like ask people being like a hidden
survey kind of thing hey so there's this
girl and basically why does he look like
that new CGI League wowie it looks
fantastic I love it
I'm getting a message live here from
meme review saying that the new improved
trailer has been leaked let's watch
[Music]
Jesus Christ I think I realized that
that Sonic is such a cultural phenomenon
at this point and how people perceive
him is so far away it's kind of like
YouTube in me when people who want and
what they put up are so different that
this is how war starts okay if they
embrace the meme okay if Sonic movie
kind of treats itself not so seriously I
think it could actually be pretty good
but of course they're not gonna do that
that's another acceptable character
design that I will let slide again with
a disappointment at least we get some on
the positive side some new meme
templates fantastic oh oh oh oh god damn
it why didn't intend to have to always
win new Team Fortress 2 live action
movie actually looks lit it looks lit
when your mom tells you to clean your
room but she doesn't know you have 35k
camera on waiting - are you really in
charge here another new meme template
fantastic reddit after forcing Paramount
animators to redesign sonic well guess
I'm in charge now when you don't have
car no car
damn and even the means are terrible Who
am I kidding here thank you for their
support and the criticism the message is
loud and clear you aren't happy with the
design I wonder this makes me really
curious what they're gonna do
endgame or detective Pikachu sonic baby
founding boomstick why are they both
doing one at the same time surely that
can't be a coincidence right
Nintendo and Sega which has been
battling since the dawn of time releases
a live action of their biggest franchise
at the same time no no no I don't think
so
james marsden just can't catch a break
james marsden made up with a very animal
and he's about to bury them their
meeting furry animal is it super easy my
god Hollywood director says they'll fix
Sonic's design for the movie the movie
might lose me in potential a soul for a
soul I prefer the real style
I said there we go Sonic what the flick
gotta go fast
you guys always act like you're better
than me there's only one thing that can
save Sonic one thing that can save the
sonic movie wears only one thing you're
gone the knuckles you heard it here
first what you never played super
simulator you know it's fun right I'm
not supposed to give my opinion but give
it a try and then you can tell me if
it's
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]